et de ce jour-là faire du sang contaminé
la cour de cassation a confirmé
aujourd'hui l'arrêt de la cour d'appel
de paris du 13 juillet 93 condamnant les
docteurs michel garretta et jean pierre
allain pour délit de tromperie mais
c'est important
la cour de cassation n'a pas exclu que
des poursuites puissent être engagées
sur le fondement de l'empoisonnement
reportage dominique verdeilhan daniel le
faire les magistrats de la cour de
cassation allait suivre l'avocat général
jean perfetti qui jeudi dernier
s'étaient portées au premier rang des
défenseurs de la thèse de
l'empoisonnement côté victimes
l'espoir était revenu seulement le droit
à quelque chose de rédhibitoire
d'hermétique mène sur les droits des
parties civiles à 104,13 les rochers
rejet c'est le moc appréhendait les
victimes il en attendait un autre cas
c'est casser les condamnations des
docteur garetta et alain pour délit de
tromperie il attendait le mot à 6
il n'est pas venu c'est pas un point
final parce que tout simplement
moi je peux pas tenir compte d'un
jugement comme ça connaissant le dossier
jeudi c'est malhonnête ce qui s'est
passé c'est une volonté de protéger
-sous dis bien un certain nombre de
personnes les victimes qui se bat depuis
maintenant très longtemps ont le courage
de ce pas trop je crois que les
magistrats auraient dû avoir le courage
de leur répondre ils ne l'ont pas ou si
vous voulez que je dise que trois ans de
travail c'est cool en quelques minutes
war
moi
je sais pas si il ya d'autres procès de
sachets pas si j'arriverai à les voir
ces prochains procès
voilà c'est tout
et le mot crime n'a pas été prononcée
parce qu'en fait la cour de cassation
n'a pas statué sur la ps2
l'empoisonnement nos juges du droit nous
disons l'information est ouverte pour
tromperie
elle s'est terminée pour tromperie à
l'article 8 de la loi de 1905 d'ailleurs
que vous pourrez sortir vos commentaires
bon ils l'ont fait ils ont fait leur
travail pas finale et l'empoisonnement
c'est autre chose en attendant toutes
nouvelles procédures les concernant les
condamnations des docteur garetta et
alain sont définitives
les deux hommes pourraient être remis en
liberté conditionnelle dans les semaines
qui viennent